well Harry and Megan's Netflix series
released to the world this morning is
packed with well not really Revelations
are they sort of rehashed old
Revelations with a new twist as it turns
out we've apparently been wrong all
along Britain is a nasty racist hell
hole where only magnificent Megan stood
up to all this and the world's biggest
victims are not the people of Ukraine or
the people battling covid or people
struggling in a devastating cost of
living crisis no the world's biggest
victims right now are the Duke and
Duchess of Netflix and don't take my
word for it
This Promise of once you're married
don't worry it'll get better
once they get used to you it'll get
better
of course it'll get better
but truth be told no matter how hard I
try no matter how good I was
no matter what I did
they were still going to find a way
to destroy me
yeah nobody set out to destroy you you
destroyed yourselves in this country
with your ludicrous hypocritical
Behavior the truth be told what she just
said is completely not a garbage Harry
and Megan's romance engagement and
marriage were all good with ecstatic Joy
by the British media the public and the
royal family that they've all now
abandoned that's the truth not Harry and
Megan's truth but the actual truth the
first three hours of this Netflix series
painted very different far uglier
picture of this country and our royal
family
eight days after the relationship became
public I put out a statement calling out
the racist undertones of Articles and
headlines that were written by the
British press I wasn't thinking about
how race played a part in any of this I
genuinely didn't think about it some of
the members of family was like right but
my wife had to go through that so why
should your girlfriend be treated any
differently why should you get special
treatment why should she be protected
and I said the difference here is the
race element I sometimes call the
Commonwealth for Empire 2.0 because that
is what it is there is a huge level of
unconscious bias the thing with
unconscious bias is it's actually no
one's fault but once it's been pointed
out or identified within yourself
you then need to make it right
yep we're all racist apparently
sounds like a different country but
let's be clear Britain's one of the most
tolerant and Multicultural nations in
the world we celebrated the Glamorous
modern Flair of neon Royals we eulogize
the newly biracial monarchies the fresh
face of 21st century Britain I wrote
newspaper columns about it myself
including on the day of the wedding the
press and public only turned on Harry
and Megan when their behavior became
obnoxious self-serving and rankedly
hypocritical sadly millions of people
around the world will watch this series
and they'll believe it they'll believe
the smears about Britain and our
monarchy that we're a bunch of bigoted
and hateful people they even blamed
brexit for the racism which apparently
was aimed at Meghan Markle which is just
completely absurd but by far the most
sickening part of this show for me was
the constant use of Harry's late mother
Princess Diana to stoke sympathy for
Megan
so much of what Megan is and how she is
so similar to my mum
she has the same compassion she has the
same empathy she has the same confidence
she has this warmth about her
I accept that there will be people
around the world who fundamentally
disagree with what I've done and how
I've done it
but I knew that I had to do everything I
could to protect my family grandma
nothing says protecting your family like
putting a kids in a reality TV series
does it
having known both women Princess Diana
and Meghan Markle you can say with
absolute certainty they're nothing in
common whatsoever I couldn't think of
two women more different when it comes
to compassion and empathy where's
Megan's been for her own father she
completely disowned him as she did all
her wedding actually before the wedding
as the series makes clear
he just suffered a stroke a few months
ago
Miss compassion hasn't even bothered to
call her father to ask how he is and the
answer is we'll find out tonight from
his son Thomas is he's not well at all
Harry's never even met
the man whose daughter he married
doesn't care Mr empathy Mr compassion
yet this man Thomas Markle raised Megan
on his own for many years that wasn't in
the documentary that was glossed over
that was ignored
just like he is now he lives 70 miles
away from them it's about an hour long
cab ride never seen his Grand
grandchildren this show is packed with a
kind of spurious
claims and hypocrisy to become a Sussex
signature we learned they began making
videos about the heroic Journey six
months before when Netflix deal was even
announced and right at the start of a
pandemic it was killing thousands of
people every day their only concern was
their own situation how mean everyone
was being to them not thousands of
people dying in the streets
clearly this is all planned from the
start the show opens with the claim the
royal family declined to come and in
fact they say no one bothered to ask
them of course their biggest complaints
are as always about the terrible media
rarely do we have a holiday without
someone with a camera you know jumping
out of a bush or something within the
family within the system the advice
that's always given is don't react there
was always public pressure with its fair
share of
drama
stress
and also tears and witnessing those
tears there's a lot of people who think
they've got such a problem with with
Paparazzi
Safety First of course in this area
we're going from one garage to another
like
Paparazzi still harass people
it's amazing what people would do when
offered a huge amount of money
to hand over photographs to create a
story
so we had to flee the country for family
privacy says Harry as we watch a hundred
million dollar documentary in which he
flaunts his young children and shares
private text messages intimate
photographs for the entire world to see
when it comes to Paparazzi I have more
Paparazzi outside my house when I was
forced to leave my old job a
disbelieving princess Pinocchio's lies
then I saw actually outside their houses
at any stage of this documentary maybe
their mob scenes are to come we haven't
seen any so far that all their claims of
Paparazzi intrusion in the two trailers
turned out to be nothing to do with them
they weren't even at many of the events
which were depicted
so forgive me if I don't think this is
all a load of BS
but frankly the biggest problem with
this series so far is that like the
Sussex themselves is actually it's dull
it's predictable it's cliche ridden it's
simperingly sycophantic it's one long
rendition of all their greatest whinges
and a lot of self-congratulatory
nonsense Harry and Megan sold their
Royal souls to become reality TV stars
but they've got the Charisma to carry
their own sob story they're not grasping
ex-royal version of the Kardashians only
with best class less loyalty and less
brains